when he's not moving around Abu show
camp for internally displaced people is
hawkh office usually spends his time at
home one of the chiefs of the camp he
says he takes his free time to pray for
the family members he lost in the Darfur
were
um
my brother Muhammad and my cousin yahia
were both killed during the start of the
war in 2003 both died just a day apart
our village was attacked by Arabs and
they fought back things were safe for a
little while but then the attackers came
back and killed them I fled with the
children
the war started in 2003 and killed more
than 300 000 people in 2007 and 2009 the
international criminal courts issued
arrest warrants for several senior
officials including then president Omar
al-Bashir the first sitting president to
be indicted by the court while in office
the court says war crimes crimes against
humanity and genocide were committed in
the western region but only one of those
wanted by the court is currently under
trial in The Hague
it wasn't only government forces but
also Rebel groups that were accused of
atrocities during the war in Darfur
survivors and other victims of arbitrary
killings forced disappearances sexual
violence and burning of villages are
demanding justice but there is little
here to indicate anyone will be held to
account
a peace dealer signed in 2020 to end the
war a year after president Bashir was
ousted and while the deal stipulates
those who committed crimes in Darfur
should be tried those here say the fact
that the government was involved makes
them doubt that will happen
the crimes against humanity the crimes
that involve government figures the
perpetrators always get away it's a big
disappointment to the revolution in 2019
when people called for justice it hurts
to see those who committed crimes
against us walking free while we
continue to suffer
is Hawk says he doesn't know if he'll
see Justice for the killings of his
family members but he says if that day
comes he'll know that the war has truly
come to an end hebo Morgan Al Jazeera
Abu show Camp North Darfur